This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When we look at the world around us, our minds are trained to fill in visual gaps, to form a more complete mental picture. So if you see a peak of a mountain in the distance, chances are pretty good, there's like a whole mountain below it. Yeah, and for the most part, that kind of mental extrapolation is really useful. When we notice part of a thing out in the world our brains automatically help us see the bigger picture. That's 9.9 PI's own, Kurt Colstead. And so before we launch the bigger episode for today, Kurt and I recently encountered a small story
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。当我们观察周围的世界时，大脑会被训练去填补视觉空白，从而形成更完整的心理图像。所以，如果你在远处看到一座山峰，很有可能下面还有整座山。没错，在大多数情况下，这种心理推断确实很有用。当我们注意到世界上的某样事物时，大脑会自动帮助我们看到更大的图景。那是《99% PI》的库尔特·科尔斯特德。在开始今天的主题之前，库尔特和我最近遇到了一个小故事，
that dovetails was something that we've covered before. It's about how our imaginations while trying to fill in those gaps sometimes lead us astray. They do. And even with things that we think we visualize really well, like for example icebergs. Anywhere you look from an inspirational poster to a kid's illustration, we think we know what icebergs look like.
它与我们之前讨论过的内容不谋而合。它是关于我们的想象力在试图填补这些空白时，有时会把我们引入歧途。确实如此。即使是我们认为自己观察得非常清楚的事物，比如冰山。无论你从励志海报还是儿童插画中看，我们都自以为很了解冰山的样子。
They look like this little rounded hump on top and the sort of spike going into the water below, sort of like a big ice cream cone. Right, I've definitely seen that before. I mean, that's the whole expression, tip of the iceberg. You see that little mound, and you see that deep spike,
它们看起来像水面上一个小小的圆顶，下面伸入水中，像一根巨大的冰淇淋蛋筒。没错，我肯定见过那种样子。我的意思是，这就是“冰山一角”这个成语的由来。你看到那个小土堆，也看到了下面深处的尖角，
and that's the whole point of the visual metaphor and the metaphor metaphor. And I've thought about that before, and I've used it a lot myself, but I'd never really considered it literally, like as in just seeing the tips of icebergs and what that really means, until I saw this image posted online by a glaciologist here.
这就是视觉隐喻和语言隐喻的全部意义所在。我以前也想过这个问题，自己也经常使用这个比喻，但我从未真正从字面上考虑过它，直到我看到一位冰川学家在网上发布的这张图片。
Just take a look. Okay, so this is an iceberg I'm assuming. It's kind of a watercolor drawing, it's pretty simple, but it's basically just like a lump of ice. It's a bit smoother than the icebergs that we are picturing in our heads before. It's more like a stone and a river. And like we've
你看一下。好吧，我假设这是一座冰山。它有点像水彩画，非常简单，基本上就是一块冰。它比我们脑海中想象的冰山要平滑一些。它更像河里的一块石头。正如我们在学校里被告知的那样，
been told about icebergs in school, most of it sits below the surface of the water, but it really doesn't look like that big cone with that deep vertical root. It really is like a scoop of ice cream rather than a cone. Exactly, and it's, you know, part of that is what you'd expect, right? You expect only a small part of it to show up above the water, but the rest of it, what you see below, it's nothing like that cone shape, right? And the woman who drew it, her name is Megantopson Munson, and she's a glaciologist,
冰山的大部分位于水面以下，但它看起来并不像那个带有深垂直根部的巨大圆锥体。它确实更像一勺冰淇淋，而不是蛋筒。没错，你知道，其中一部分是你所预料的，对吧？你预料只有一小部分会出现在水面上，但剩下的部分，你在水下看到的那部分，根本不像那种圆锥形状，对吧？画这幅画的女士名叫梅根·托普森·芒森，她是一位冰川学家，
and she posted this watercolor online with a really specific call to action. Basically, she argues that we need to rethink how we represent icebergs. I mean, I think I can see the problem just in her drawing itself. We're taught that 10% is above the water, and this shows, you know, basically 10% is above the water, but it doesn't have that deep vertical configuration. Because when you think about it, that doesn't make any sense if you put like a pool noodle
她在网上发布了这幅水彩画，并提出了一个非常具体的行动呼吁。基本上，她认为我们需要重新思考如何表现冰山。我的意思是，我觉得光看她的画就能看出问题所在。我们被教导说10%在水面上，这幅画也显示，你知道，基本上10%在水面上，但它没有那种深层的垂直结构。因为当你仔细想想，如果你把一根泳池浮棒
in a pool, it wouldn't stand upright, it goes on its side. Exactly, and that's her point, right? It's like, you know, once you think about it, you kind of get it, but you have to think about it first. So in light of this misconception, she's urging other scientists to think about it and to draw icebergs in quote, stable orientations. So this is just one example and all icebergs are presumably different. How do you know what the
放进泳池里，它不会直立，而是会侧着漂浮。没错，这就是她的观点，对吧？你知道，一旦你思考一下，你就会明白，但你必须先去思考。鉴于这种误解，她敦促其他科学家思考这个问题，并以所谓的“稳定方向”来绘制冰山。所以这只是一个例子，所有的冰山大概都是不同的。你怎么知道
orientation should be? What you should be picturing? Well, that's a thing. Once she put this image up online, right? This software developer came into the thread and his name is Joshua Tauber and he was basically inspired by her post to make this website called Icebricker. And it's really simple. It just lets you draw ice shapes and see how they float. So for example, if you draw a cone, it will slowly reorient that cone to float on its side. And you can sort of see that shift in slow motion too. So you can kind of see the physics in action. And in the end, it lines up at this stable orientation. That's so cool. Yeah, this is like, you show me a picture of a cone. And now it's definitely a cone that's like, sadly, on its side.
方向应该是怎样的？你应该想象什么？嗯，这就是关键。她把这张图片发到网上后，一位软件开发人员加入了讨论，他的名字叫约书亚·陶伯，他基本上是受她的帖子启发，制作了这个名为“Icebricker”的网站。它非常简单。它只是让你画出冰的形状，然后看看它们是如何漂浮的。例如，如果你画一个圆锥体，它会慢慢调整那个圆锥体，让它侧着漂浮。你也可以慢动作看到这种转变。所以你可以看到物理学在起作用。最后，它会调整到这个稳定的方向。太酷了。是的，就像你给我看一张圆锥体的图片，现在它肯定是一个悲伤地侧躺着的圆锥体。
So the idea with iceberger is you just trace out any shape. And then it'll just rotate till it finds its level. And that's how it would behave in nature. Exactly, that's exactly it. And the site has sub-disclaimers, like, you know, real icebergs are three-dimensionally complex. The densities are going to be a little different. So, so the website is just sort of a simple intuition aid, more than a scientific tool.
所以“Icebricker”的想法就是你勾勒出任何形状。然后它会旋转直到找到平衡点。这就是它在自然界中的表现方式。没错，就是这样。该网站有一些免责声明，比如，你知道，真实的冰山在三维上很复杂。密度也会有所不同。所以，这个网站更多是一个简单的直觉辅助工具，而不是一个科学工具。
And the main point is just to give you a better idea of what might happen, roughly speaking, to various shapes, like this one. This is a cat. This is a trino cat. This is a cat. And so this is like what if there was a cat shaped iceberg and when you see it, it's actually surprisingly stable configuration of the cats head above the water and the tail above the water, but it is pretty funny. Yeah, it is. And odds are maybe some part of this would break off like the tail in real life.
主要目的是让你更好地了解各种形状可能会发生什么，大致来说，比如这个。这是一只猫。这是一只三诺猫。这是一只猫。所以这就是如果有一座猫形的冰山会怎样，当你看到它时，猫头在水面上，尾巴在水面上，这实际上是一个令人惊讶的稳定结构，但确实很有趣。是的，确实。而且很有可能在现实生活中，这其中的一部分会断裂，比如尾巴。
But it does give you an idea that like, okay, what you see above the surface and what you can imagine underwater can be very different, right? And it's just kind of funny. So other than getting inaccurate scientific picture to sort of come back, this proverbial vision of what we have of icebergs, why is it important to visualize icebergs properly? Like, why was this Macon's hill to die on? Well, I think it was, it was her glacier to die in in part because she's a glacialologist, right?
但这确实让你明白，好吧，你在水面上看到的和你能在水下想象的可能非常不同，对吧？这很有趣。所以，除了纠正我们对冰山那种众所周知的、不准确的科学印象之外，正确地可视化冰山为什么很重要？为什么梅根要坚持这一点？嗯，我认为这是她作为冰川学家的执着，对吧？
And practically speaking, okay, there's not a whole lot of application for this, right? If you're boating close to an iceberg, it is good to know that an iceberg could spread out a ways under the water. that way, you might avoid hitting it. But really, it speaks to this larger issue in many scientists, like geology, where so much of the world is invisible to us, right? So my dad, for example, is a geophysicist.
从实际角度来看，好吧，这并没有太多的应用价值，对吧？如果你在冰山附近划船，知道冰山在水下可能会延伸一段距离是件好事。这样，你可能会避免撞到它。但实际上，它反映了许多科学领域（如地质学）中一个更大的问题，即世界上大部分事物对我们来说是不可见的，对吧？比如我父亲，他是一位地球物理学家。
And when he's explaining big planetary physical phenomena and change over time, like how tectonic plates shift around the world, visual aids are completely essential. So the bigger issue is representing things more scientifically in general, whether it be icebergs in pop culture or scientific diagrams and textbooks or scientific diagrams on the news or something like that. Right. It's like as long as we're going to try to represent these things, we might as well get it right, you know, for the sake of education and for the sake of really understanding the world around us. Sure. And what this fairly specific and smaller story made me think of was Emmett's 99PI episode on dinosaurs. It's about how drawings have both been shaped by,
当他解释巨大的行星物理现象和随时间的变化时，比如构造板块如何在世界各地移动，视觉辅助工具是绝对必要的。所以更大的问题是普遍地更科学地表现事物，无论是流行文化中的冰山，还是教科书中的科学图表，或者是新闻中的科学图表等等。没错。就像只要我们要尝试表现这些事物，我们最好还是把它做对，你知道，为了教育，也为了真正理解我们周围的世界。当然。这个相当具体且较小的故事让我想起了埃米特关于恐龙的《99PI》剧集。它是关于绘画如何既被古生物学塑造，
but have also shaped the discipline of paleontology. And like glaciologists or geologists, paleontologists have this important role in helping us visualize things. But like these other scientists, they have to extrapolate at times too, based on whatever evidence they have. So evidence like the fossilized bones of dinosaurs
同时也塑造了古生物学这门学科。像冰川学家或地质学家一样，古生物学家在帮助我们可视化事物方面发挥着重要作用。但像这些科学家一样，他们有时也必须根据他们拥有的任何证据进行推断。所以证据，比如恐龙的化石骨骼，
or even the sort of modern genetic relatives of dinosaurs, that's how we extrapolate what they look like. Yeah, exactly. And so icebergs are kind of this great contemporary physical example, but they're also this useful analogy, right? It's really easy to use icebergs to explain how we sometimes can't see what's
甚至是恐龙的现代遗传亲属，这就是我们推断它们长相的方式。是的，没错。所以冰山是一种很好的当代物理例子，但它们也是一个有用的类比，对吧？用冰山来解释我们有时为什么看不到
below the surface. And they hinted at this larger challenge that scientists face more broadly, like how do we picture what we can't see? And it turns out that's a much deeper question. On that note, we're going to revisit Emmett Fitzgerald's story called Welcome to Jurassic Art. And while listening, you might want to keep other scientific disciplines in mind, because it probably applies to most of them. Anyone who has had kids knows that they go through obsessive phases that can last anywhere from a few days to several years.
水面下的东西非常容易。它们暗示了科学家面临的更广泛的挑战，即我们如何想象我们看不见的东西？事实证明，这是一个更深层次的问题。说到这里，我们将重温埃米特·菲茨杰拉德的故事，名为《欢迎来到侏罗纪艺术》。在听的时候，你可能想记住其他科学学科，因为它可能适用于大多数学科。任何有孩子的人都知道，他们会经历痴迷阶段，这些阶段可能持续几天到几年不等。
I went through a lot of phases growing up. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. There was a brief train phase, then in preschool I was obsessed with farming equipment. I could list obscure European tractor brands off the top of my head like an old Italian wheat farmer. But I think my most intense obsession, like many kids, was dinosaurs. I knew more about dinosaurs at the age of five than I do now.
我在成长过程中经历过很多阶段。那是制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。有一段短暂的火车阶段，然后在学龄前我痴迷于农用设备。我可以像一位老意大利小麦农夫一样，随口列出晦涩的欧洲拖拉机品牌。但我认为我最强烈的痴迷，像许多孩子一样，是恐龙。我在五岁时对恐龙的了解比现在还要多。
And I was all but certain that I would one day become a paleontologist. I don't know exactly where this dinosaur obsession came from, but I think part of it was just that dinosaurs looked so cool. I had all these books filled with incredible drawings of colorful dinosaurs leaping around roaring and tearing into one another. I fell in love with the artwork in those books. And at least for the time being, art is the only way we experience dinosaurs. We can study bones and fossils, but barring the invention of time travel or some drastic park resurrection scenario, we will never see these animals with our own eyes. There are no photos or video, which means that if we want to picture how they look, someone has to draw them.
而且我几乎确信有一天我会成为一名古生物学家。我不知道这种恐龙痴迷究竟从何而来，但我认为部分原因只是因为恐龙看起来太酷了。我所有的书里都装满了令人难以置信的彩色恐龙跳跃、咆哮和互相撕咬的图画。我爱上了那些书里的艺术作品。而且至少目前为止，艺术是我们体验恐龙的唯一方式。我们可以研究骨骼和化石，但除非发明了时间旅行或某种剧烈的公园复活场景，否则我们永远不会亲眼看到这些动物。没有照片或视频，这意味着如果我们想想象它们的样子，就必须有人把它们画出来。
Hello, I'm Dr. Robert Bucker, known to the folks in North Texas as Jurassic Bob. I dig bones, dinosaur bones. Bob Bucker is one of the most famous living paleontologists, and he also happens to be a very skilled paleo artist. He thinks the two go hand in hand. Art is very important in teaching natural history science, maybe all science. Teach everyone art and everyone music too patterns.
你好，我是罗伯特·巴克博士，北德克萨斯州的人们称我为“侏罗纪鲍勃”。我挖掘骨头，恐龙骨头。鲍勃·巴克是现存最著名的古生物学家之一，而且他恰好也是一位非常熟练的古生物艺术家。他认为两者相辅相成。艺术在教授自然历史科学方面非常重要，也许对所有科学都是如此。教每个人艺术，也教每个人音乐，教他们模式。
Geez. I like Bob a lot. When I interviewed him in a studio in Boulder, Colorado, he showed up an hour early and he brought his own snacks. He's got snacks here. He's got coffee and some apple pie. Free range apple pie. This is so liberal this place. This is so bolder. Cage free apple pie. Once we got started with our interview, Bob said that like me,
天哪。我很喜欢鲍勃。当我在科罗拉多州博尔德市的一个工作室采访他时，他提前一小时到了，还带了自己的零食。他这里有零食。他有咖啡和一些苹果派。散养苹果派。这个地方太自由派了。这太博尔德了。笼养苹果派。我们开始采访后，鲍勃说像我一样，
he got obsessed with dinosaurs and dinosaur art pretty early on. How I got hooked was a piece of journalism from 1953, Life Magazine, cover story called The World We Live In, and pictures of dinosaurs and whatnot. The cover image was the head of a long necked dinosaur sitting in a swamp, munching on grass, with a stegosaurus in the background sort of staring off into space.
他很早就痴迷于恐龙和恐龙艺术。我迷上它是因为1953年的一篇新闻报道，《生活》杂志的封面故事，名为《我们生活的世界》，里面有恐龙之类的图片。封面图片是一只长颈恐龙的头坐在沼泽里，咀嚼着草，背景中有一只剑龙正盯着虚空发呆。
And inside was this long article about evolution. After two hours with that life magazine, I announced to my startled parents, mom and dad I wanna grow up and be a vertebrate paleontologist. And dad had no expression, and mom smiled and said, that's nice dear, it's a stage you'll outgrow. But unlike me, dinosaurs weren't just the childhood phase for Jurassic Bob.
里面有一篇关于进化的长文章。在那本《生活》杂志上看了两个小时后，我向我吃惊的父母宣布：妈妈，爸爸，我想长大后成为一名脊椎动物古生物学家。爸爸面无表情，妈妈微笑着说，那很好，亲爱的，这只是一个你会长大的阶段。但与我不同的是，恐龙对“侏罗纪鲍勃”来说不仅仅是童年的一个阶段。
By the time he headed off to college, a career in vertebrate paleontology was still the game plan. But it was kind of a strange time to be entering the field. In the mid-20th century, American dinosaur science was in a bit of a rut. Dinosaurs were considered big, dumb, cold-blooded reptiles, evolutionary failures, destined for extinction. And that view of dinosaurs affected how they were painted and drawn. Most of the paintings of dinosaurs, they're not moving, they're not interacting with each other. There's no spark of intelligence, social life.
当他上大学时，脊椎动物古生物学的职业生涯仍然是他的计划。但进入这个领域是一个奇怪的时期。在20世纪中期，美国恐龙科学陷入了困境。恐龙被认为是巨大、愚蠢、冷血的爬行动物，是进化的失败者，注定要灭绝。这种对恐龙的看法影响了它们的绘画和描绘方式。大多数恐龙画作中，它们不动，它们不与彼此互动。没有智慧的火花，没有社交生活。
And their bodies were like hulking masses of flesh. The way Brontosaurus and Diplodicus, the biggest dinosaurs, were illustrated. They were like giant gray vacuum cleaners with very, very short legs. And they were slowly pulling themselves across the landscape or sitting neck deep and a fetted swamp. Gunnosaurs were often drawn sitting in swamps like on that live magazine cover. The thinking was they were so large they
它们的身体就像笨重的肉块。雷龙和梁龙，这些最大的恐龙，被描绘的方式。它们就像巨大的灰色吸尘器，腿非常非常短。它们缓慢地在景观中拖动自己，或者坐在深及脖子的恶臭沼泽中。恐龙经常被画成坐在沼泽里，就像那本《生活》杂志的封面一样。当时的观点是它们太大了，
couldn't possibly hold up their own body weight. And if they were drawn on land they usually dragged their fat tails behind them as they walked. And that's where we were in the early 1960s. Dinosaurs were sad, co-blooded dead ends in the history of life. But paleontology was about to go through. A spectacular and unanticipated U-turn. And a young Bob Bocker just off to college would find himself right in the thick of the action.
不可能支撑自己的体重。如果它们被画在陆地上，它们走路时通常会拖着肥大的尾巴。这就是我们在20世纪60年代初所处的位置。恐龙是生命史上悲伤、冷血的死胡同。但古生物学即将经历一次壮观且意想不到的急转弯。而刚上大学的年轻鲍勃·巴克发现自己正处于行动的中心。
Freshman Year, the Yale Geology Department took me, bunch of other freshmen, out today. The trip out west was led by one of Bob's professors at Yale, a paleontologist named John Ostrom. And among other things, we dug up four raptures. They were a new species of raptor that Professor Ostrom named Dynonicus. Meaning terrible claw. And the bones were found really close together.
大一那年，耶鲁大学地质系带我和其他一些新生出去。这次西部之行由鲍勃在耶鲁的一位教授领导，他是一位名叫约翰·奥斯特罗姆的古生物学家。除其他事项外，我们挖出了四只猛禽。它们是一个新的猛禽物种，奥斯特罗姆教授将其命名为“恐爪龙”。意思是“可怕的爪子”。这些骨头被发现靠得很近。
Presumably they'd lived together. They were a pack, maybe intelligent. But what really got Professor Ostrom excited was the anatomy of the skeleton. After studying the fossil remains back at Yale, Ostrom concluded that dinonicus had not been a slow, plotting swamp creature. It had been fleet-footed, agile, and extremely active. Ostrom began to argue that if you really looked at the anatomy of many dinosaurs, they looked less like lumbering lizards and more like super athletic birds.
据推测它们住在一起。它们是一个群体，也许很聪明。但真正让奥斯特罗姆教授兴奋的是骨骼的解剖结构。在耶鲁研究化石遗骸后，奥斯特罗姆得出结论，恐爪龙不是一种缓慢、沉重的沼泽生物。它曾是脚步轻快、敏捷且极其活跃的。奥斯特罗姆开始争辩说，如果你真的观察许多恐龙的解剖结构，它们看起来不像笨重的蜥蜴，而更像超级运动型的鸟类。
And his student, Bob Bacher, found this idea really compelling. He remembers looking at a skeleton of a different dinosaur called Ornithelestys. He really did look like a road runner with a long-boned tail and teeth, but wow, it just spoke agility. But then you read the textbooks and you're not supposed to believe that. As an undergraduate, Bacher dissected modern animals in an effort to better understand dinosaur musculature. And he concluded that the old stereotypes about stupid sluggish dinosaurs just didn't hold up. They weren't slow and sloppy. Now, this idea wasn't totally new.
他的学生鲍勃·巴克发现这个想法非常引人注目。他记得看着另一种名为“鸟脚龙”的恐龙骨架。它看起来确实像一只长着长骨尾巴和牙齿的走鹃，哇，它简直就是敏捷的代名词。但后来你读教科书，你不应该相信这一点。作为本科生，巴克解剖了现代动物，试图更好地理解恐龙的肌肉结构。他得出结论，关于愚蠢、迟钝恐龙的旧刻板印象根本站不住脚。它们并不缓慢和邋遢。现在，这个想法并不完全是新的。
Bacher says that for decades, going back as early as the mid-19th century, there had been people saying that dinosaurs were smart, active, and bird-like. But these facts were forgotten about, really. They dropped out of textbooks. So Bokker decided to publish a paper in a Yale journal, and his editor says, I know what you should call this study, and I said, what? She said, you should call it the superiority of dinosaurs. I said, yeah, that's it. They weren't evolutionary husbands.
巴克说，几十年来，早在19世纪中期，就有人说恐龙是聪明、活跃且像鸟类的。但这些事实真的被遗忘了。它们从教科书中消失了。所以巴克决定在耶鲁的一本期刊上发表一篇论文，他的编辑说，我知道你应该给这项研究起什么名字，我说，什么？她说，你应该称之为“恐龙的优越性”。我说，是的，就是这样。它们不是进化的失败者。
They weren't dead ends in the flow of Darwinian process. They were top of the line. They beat everybody. But convincing people that dinosaurs were actually totally different than they had been depicted for the past 60 years was going to require more than a few good academic papers to really change people's minds. Sometimes you got a show instead of tell. And remember, Bocker was a skilled illustrator as well as a scientist.
它们不是达尔文进化过程中的死胡同。它们是顶级的。它们打败了所有人。但要让人们相信恐龙实际上与过去60年所描绘的完全不同，需要不仅仅是几篇好的学术论文来真正改变人们的想法。有时你必须展示而不是讲述。记住，巴克不仅是一位科学家，还是一位熟练的插画家。
And so when John Ostrom wrote his definitive paper on Dynanicus, he asked Bokker to do the illustration. And I positioned the bones as if his raptor was running. In the picture, the raptor is nearly parallel with the ground. It's left leg springing forward, it's right leg curled tightly against its torso, preparing for the the next ride. The tail is high in the air, it's beautiful and kind of terrifying. Austro put the picture right on the front of his paper, and it quickly became an iconic drawing. No one had ever seen anything quite like it. Bacca is like a renegade. This is Darren Niche, a paleontologist based in the UK.
所以当约翰·奥斯特罗姆写他关于恐爪龙的权威论文时，他请巴克做插图。我把骨头摆放成这只猛禽正在奔跑的样子。在图片中，猛禽几乎与地面平行。左腿向前弹跳，右腿紧紧蜷缩在躯干上，准备下一次跨步。尾巴高高翘起，既美丽又有点可怕。奥斯特罗姆把这张图片直接放在了他论文的封面上，它很快成为了一幅标志性的画作。没有人见过这样的东西。巴克就像一个叛逆者。这是达伦·奈什，一位驻英国的古生物学家。
He's got like a flamboyant appearance, he insists on wearing a cowboy hat all the time, he's got a giant bushy beard, and right from the late 60s, when he's starting to talk about this stuff, he's drawing these agile, active dinosaurs. Bacher finished up at Yale and went off to graduate school, where he continued to speak truth to the slow, dumb dinosaur establishment.
他外表华丽，坚持一直戴着牛仔帽，留着巨大的浓密胡子，从60年代末开始，当他开始谈论这些东西时，他就在画这些敏捷、活跃的恐龙。巴克在耶鲁毕业后去了研究生院，在那里他继续向缓慢、愚蠢的恐龙机构说真话。
He wrote academic and popular articles about how impressive dinosaurs had been. And he illustrated them all himself. He drew dinosaurs bounding across the prehistoric landscape like track and field stars, with live muscular bodies. So prior to this time, an animal like Tyrannosaurus would have been drawn as like a guldzilla-type animal dragon it's telling the ground, it's not a particularly attractive beast. But under backer you've got this thing shown with massive, bulging muscles. And Bakker's athletic dinosaurs became a model for other paleoartists.
他写了学术和大众文章，讲述恐龙是多么令人印象深刻。而且他自己画了所有的插图。他画的恐龙像田径明星一样在史前景观中跳跃，有着充满活力的肌肉身体。所以在此之前，像霸王龙这样的动物会被画成哥斯拉那样的动物，拖着尾巴在地上，那不是一种特别吸引人的野兽。但在巴克笔下，你看到的东西有着巨大的、隆起的肌肉。巴克的运动型恐龙成为了其他古生物艺术家的典范。
So when my dinonicus drawing appeared, some artis younger than I said, huh, okay, now we can do it. Artists like Gregory Paul embrace this new, exciting vision of dinosaurs. They started giving their dinosaurs vibrant colors and occasionally feathers to really emphasize their birdiness. Soon, images of athletic, colorful dinosaurs were everywhere. And they helped fuel the revolution that was taking place in paleontology. Throughout the 70s, more and more paleontologists got on board with Austro and Bacchers theories.
所以当我的恐爪龙画作出现时，一些比我年轻的艺术家说，嗯，好吧，现在我们可以这样做了。像格雷戈里·保罗这样的艺术家拥抱了这种新的、令人兴奋的恐龙愿景。他们开始给他们的恐龙赋予鲜艳的颜色，有时还有羽毛，以真正强调它们的鸟类特征。很快，运动型、色彩鲜艳的恐龙图片随处可见。它们帮助推动了古生物学正在发生的革命。在整个70年代，越来越多的古生物学家加入了奥斯特罗姆和巴克的理论。
They found new fossils and footprint evidence suggesting that dinosaurs have been more blooded, intelligent, and bird-like. This period has become known as the dinosaur renaissance, a moment when we totally rethought all of our assumptions about these incredible prehistoric animals. In Derenace, things art was a huge part of its success. I think that part of the reason that the dinosaurs of the dinosaurs were nice ones, the dinosaurs of Auschmann and Bacchus, drew in so many scientists in the 1670s, was because it was accompanied by brilliant visuals. If anyone missed out on this scientific revolution and still thought that dinosaurs were slow and stupid,
他们发现了新的化石和足迹证据，表明恐龙是更热血、更聪明、更像鸟类的。这段时期被称为“恐龙文艺复兴”，这是一个我们彻底重新思考关于这些令人难以置信的史前动物的所有假设的时刻。在文艺复兴时期，艺术是其成功的重要组成部分。我认为恐龙文艺复兴时期的恐龙，奥斯特罗姆和巴克的恐龙，之所以在60、70年代吸引了这么多科学家，是因为它伴随着辉煌的视觉效果。如果有人错过了这场科学革命，仍然认为恐龙是缓慢而愚蠢的，
that ended in 1993. The dinosaurs in Jurassic Park are very active. The dinosaurs in Jurassic Park are very active. The dinosaurs of Jurassic Park in 1993, they are the dinosaur renaissance, dinosaurs. And when that movie came out, the whole world got to see these fierce athletic creatures running through kitchens and eating lawyers off of toilets. athletic creatures running through kitchens and eating lawyers off of toilets. And once you've seen the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park, you can't unsee them. I think it cemented the notion of athletic dinosaurs. This is John Conway. He draws dinosaurs for a living.
那在1993年就结束了。《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙非常活跃。《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙非常活跃。《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙，在1993年，它们就是恐龙文艺复兴时期的恐龙。当那部电影上映时，全世界都看到了这些凶猛的运动型生物在厨房里奔跑，把律师从厕所里吃掉。一旦你看到了《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙，你就无法忘记它们。我认为它巩固了运动型恐龙的概念。这是约翰·康威。他以画恐龙为生。
I'm a paleo artist, which means that I draw in paint, prehistoric animals. Conway got interested in paleo art after reading Bob Bocker's book, The Dinosaur Heresies. And in the early part of his career, he drew dinosaurs that looked a lot like Bocker's, super lean and mussely. But after a while, he started to feel kind of funny about it. He says that all of his dinosaurs looked like they had been shrink wrapped. You know those suction pack, you pack your clothes and you put the vacuum cleaner on it and you suck all the air out and it shrinks it down. That's sort of what we were doing with dinosaurs.
我是一名古生物艺术家，这意味着我画史前动物。康威在读了鲍勃·巴克的书《恐龙异端》后对古生物艺术产生了兴趣。在他职业生涯的早期，他画的恐龙看起来很像巴克的，超级瘦削且肌肉发达。但过了一段时间，他开始觉得有点不对劲。他说他所有的恐龙看起来都像是被真空包装了一样。你知道那些真空袋，你把衣服装进去，用吸尘器把空气抽干，它就会收缩。我们对恐龙做的就是那样。
We were sort of putting skin on them and then vacuuming out anything that was in between that skin and the muscles. Now paleoartists weren't just doing that to make their dinosaurs look all cool and buff. They were trying to be accurate. I am part of the generation of paleoartis that grew up from a young age when we first started to think that it really mattered to get things right. And to get things right, you want your art to be rooted in real scientific evidence. And the main piece of evidence was often a skeleton.
我们给它们穿上皮肤，然后把皮肤和肌肉之间的任何东西都抽走。现在，古生物艺术家这样做不仅仅是为了让他们的恐龙看起来很酷和强壮。他们试图做到准确。我是那一代古生物艺术家的一部分，我们从小就开始认为把事情做对真的很重要。为了把事情做对，你希望你的艺术植根于真实的科学证据。而主要的证据通常是骨架。
Paleoartists would base the shape of their dinosaurs on an accurate skeleton. The bones give you a pretty good idea where the muscles should go, but soft issues like skin, and cartilage, and fat are much harder. Fat usually doesn't survive for millions of years in fossils. And so, without any evidence of it, paleoartists tended to be pretty conservative about how much fat they gave their dinosaurs. Which makes total sense, you're not going to add something that you don't have evidence for. But the result was that all these dinosaurs looked like they went to the gym three times a day, and drank protein shakes for every meal. John Conway says it began to feel as though paleoartists had replaced one orthodoxy with
古生物艺术家会根据准确的骨架来确定恐龙的形状。骨头让你很好地了解肌肉应该在哪里，但软组织，如皮肤、软骨和脂肪，要难得多。脂肪通常不会在化石中保存数百万年。因此，在没有任何证据的情况下，古生物艺术家在给恐龙添加多少脂肪方面往往非常保守。这完全说得通，你不会添加你没有证据的东西。但结果是，所有这些恐龙看起来都像是每天去三次健身房，每顿饭都喝蛋白粉。约翰·康威说，这开始让人觉得古生物艺术家已经用一种正统观念取代了另一种。
another. At some point, I thought, you know, we can't just keep doing this. This is not interesting in many ways, and is it even right? Is this conservative approach really giving people the right notion about what dinosaurs looked like? Just because fat didn't survive for millions of years doesn't mean that a dinosaur didn't have it. They are animals after all. So animals have fat and they have it all over the place. And some places they have really big fat reserve, which changes their shape fairly drastically.
在某个时候，我想，你知道，我们不能一直这样做。这在很多方面都不有趣，而且这甚至正确吗？这种保守的方法真的给了人们关于恐龙长相的正确概念吗？仅仅因为脂肪没有保存数百万年，并不意味着恐龙没有脂肪。毕竟它们是动物。所以动物有脂肪，而且它们到处都有。在某些地方，它们有非常大的脂肪储备，这相当剧烈地改变了它们的形状。
To underscore this point, Conway asked me to consider a thought experiment. If we reconstructed modern animals, like we reconstruct dinosaurs, what would they look like? In other words, if some alien paleontologist from millions of years in the future was to try and draw a modern animal, like say a whale or a camel, just from their fossilized skeleton.
为了强调这一点，康威让我考虑一个思想实验。如果我们像重建恐龙一样重建现代动物，它们会是什么样子？换句话说，如果未来数百万年后的某个外星古生物学家试图根据化石骨架画出一只现代动物，比如鲸鱼或骆驼。
How would it look? Well, if you actually do it, the modern animals look ridiculous. If you draw a bowhead whale, for example, just from the skeleton, without a lot of fat or blubber, it looks kind of like a giant tadpole with a bulbous head and a long, sneak-like tail. I mean, you take away all that stuff and you're not left with much whale. Because whales, their shape is defined by fat. Dinosaurs also had fat, and John argues that it would have changed their shape pretty dramatically.
它会是什么样子？嗯，如果你真的这样做，现代动物看起来很荒谬。例如，如果你只根据骨架画一只弓头鲸，没有大量的脂肪或鲸脂，它看起来有点像一只巨大的蝌蚪，有一个球状的头和一条长长的、像蛇一样的尾巴。我的意思是，你拿走所有那些东西，剩下的鲸鱼就不多了。因为鲸鱼的形状是由脂肪定义的。恐龙也有脂肪，约翰认为这会相当剧烈地改变它们的形状。
Who knows, some might have even had humps like camels. Yeah, you could take one of the most familiar dinosaurs. That dinosaur could have camel humps, and we wouldn't know. Right? Because you can't tell from a camel's back that it has humps. You just can't. There's not really anything there. Brontosaurus could have had humps?
谁知道呢，有些甚至可能有像骆驼一样的驼峰。是的，你可以拿走最熟悉的恐龙之一。那只恐龙可能有骆驼峰，而我们却不知道。对吧？因为你从骆驼的背上看不出它有驼峰。你就是看不出来。那里真的没什么东西。雷龙可能有驼峰吗？
We don't know. Now scientists do sometimes find dinosaur fossils with the soft tissues intact, and when they do, they can completely change our image of the animal. The dinosaur satecosaurus, for example, used to be depicted in a standard shrink-wrapped kind of way. Until paleontologists found this amazing full-body fossil, where lots of the fat and the skin and the different soft tissues had been perfectly preserved.
我们不知道。现在科学家有时会发现软组织完好的恐龙化石，当他们发现时，它们可以彻底改变我们对这种动物的形象。例如，鹦鹉嘴龙过去常以一种标准的真空包装方式被描绘。直到古生物学家发现了这个惊人的全身化石，其中许多脂肪、皮肤和不同的软组织被完美地保存了下来。
Turns out. The fleshy outline around the body was quite extensive. It was quite a chubby creature. There's striping all over the place, all over the body. And growing off the top of the tail, it's got like a hundred long curving quills. They look kind of like floppy porcupine quills. And like you add all that together, that's a creature that's, we just would not predict that based on just finding bones alone. In recent years, fossils have been found with fat and frills and thick coats of feathers. We more than anyone had predicted. So it turns out every time we discover something like this, it's weird. And that got me thinking,
事实证明。身体周围的肉质轮廓相当广泛。它是一个相当胖乎乎的生物。全身到处都是条纹。尾巴顶部生长着大约一百根长而弯曲的刺。它们看起来有点像松软的豪猪刺。把所有这些加在一起，那是一个我们仅仅根据发现骨头根本无法预测的生物。近年来，人们发现了带有脂肪、褶边和厚羽毛层的化石。我们比任何人预测的都要多。所以事实证明，每次我们发现这样的东西，它都很奇怪。这让我开始思考，
so if all the ones we've discovered so far have turned out to be pretty weird, what does that tell us about the rest of them? There are bizarre possibilities out there that no one's looking at. And I thought, well, I'm going to start drawing some of these things. So John began to draw something new with his art. He started to speculate. to draw something new with his art. He started to speculate. He started drawing pudgy dinosaurs and dinosaurs with pumps and quills and weird skin flaps. And that was my rule.
所以如果到目前为止我们发现的所有恐龙都变得相当奇怪，那这告诉了我们关于其余恐龙的什么信息？外面有没人关注的奇异可能性。我想，好吧，我要开始画一些这样的东西了。所以约翰开始用他的艺术画一些新的东西。他开始推测。他开始画胖乎乎的恐龙，以及带有驼峰、刺和奇怪皮肤褶皱的恐龙。这就是我的规则。
It was, how far can we go? What's the most outrageous thing I can do that we don't know, isn't true, right? It's still within the realms of possibility. It's not falsified. John wasn't just making stuff up out of thin air. It was like there was a standard conservative dinosaur at the center of his drawings,
它是，我们可以走多远？我能做的最离谱的事情是什么，我们不知道它不是真的，对吧？它仍然在可能性的范围内。它没有被证伪。约翰不仅仅是凭空捏造。就像他的画作中心有一个标准的保守恐龙，
and then Cami would cover it with more speculative elements. He wasn't claiming that every drawing he did was perfectly accurate, but he wanted to show people that dinosaurs as a group probably had a lot more weird variety than we think. And so, to get the overall picture of dinosaurs right, I think you need a healthy dose of speculation in there. Conway says that dinosaur art should always reflect the latest science, what we know for sure. But we'll never know everything. And I think the speculation is about what extra bits of weird beauty were in the world
然后康威会用更多推测性的元素覆盖它。他并不是声称他画的每一幅画都是完全准确的，但他想向人们展示，作为一个群体的恐龙可能比我们想象的要多得多奇怪的多样性。所以，为了得到恐龙的整体图景，我认为你需要适量的推测。康威说，恐龙艺术应该始终反映最新的科学，我们确定的东西。但我们永远不会知道一切。我认为推测是关于世界上还有什么额外的奇怪美感
back then that we'll just never know about. The role of the artist is to bring back some of that real magic as a prehistoric world that was certainly there. John eventually decided to give the world some of that magic in the form of a book. He teamed up with Darren Nash and another paleo artist named Memo Cosmon and published a slim little paperback called All Yesterdays. All yesterdays is filled with dinosaurs that look very different from what you're used to.
那时我们永远不会知道。艺术家的角色是带回一些那种真实的魔力，作为一个史前世界，它肯定在那里。约翰最终决定以书的形式给世界带来一些那种魔力。他与达伦·奈什和另一位名叫梅莫·科斯蒙的古生物艺术家合作，出版了一本薄薄的平装书，名为《所有昨天》。《所有昨天》里装满了看起来与你习惯的非常不同的恐龙。
There's a triceratops that's covered in spines, a magunga-saurus with skin that camouflages it against the forest floor, and a pharaohzinosaurus that is so covered in spines, a magunga-saurus with skin that camouflage that against the forest floor, and a pharaohzina-saurus that is so covered in feathers it looks like a haystack. And next to each image, the artist describes why they drew it that way. The camouflage dinosaur is drawn that way because the artist reason that its oddly proportioned body
有一只覆盖着刺的三角龙，一只皮肤可以伪装在森林地面的马贡加龙，还有一只覆盖着羽毛看起来像干草堆的镰刀龙。在每张图片旁边，艺术家描述了他们为什么那样画。那只伪装的恐龙之所以那样画，是因为艺术家推断它比例奇怪的身体
might have made it vulnerable to predators and in need of some kind of defense strategy. All yesterday's was a big hit, and it helped spark a little movement for more speculative paleo art. We talk about the all yesterday's movement as like, is the new frontier of the way we should depict prehistoric animals. Daringnish says it's more acceptable now to draw a dinosaur based on a hypothesis. For example, horn dinosaurs like triceratops have these absurdly large nostrils that have confused paleontologists for years. There have been a few different hypotheses but forward by scientists, and one of them is that the dinosaurs may have had inflatable nose balloons.
可能使它容易受到捕食者的攻击，需要某种防御策略。《所有昨天》大受欢迎，它帮助引发了一场关于更具推测性的古生物艺术的小运动。我们谈论“所有昨天”运动，就像它是我们应该描绘史前动物方式的新前沿。达伦·奈什说，现在根据假设画恐龙更容易被接受。例如，像三角龙这样的角龙有这些荒谬的大鼻孔，多年来一直困扰着古生物学家。科学家们提出了几种不同的假设，其中之一是恐龙可能有充气的鼻子气球。
Kind of like elephant seal or hooded seal inflatable pouches, but just would have looked weird and grotesque and utterly alien to us, but that's a very real possibility. Now, 20 years ago, if someone were to draw triceratops with nose balloons, they would have been laughed at. But I would say that what we call the all yesterday's movement means that it is now quite reasonable for an artist to say, I've shown my traceritops with giant inflatable nose balloons for this reason. And you could say, no, don't do it, that's too speculative,
有点像象海豹或冠海豹的充气囊，但这看起来会很奇怪、怪诞，对我们来说完全陌生，但这是一种非常真实的可能性。现在，20年前，如果有人画出带有鼻子气球的三角龙，他们会被嘲笑。但我会说，我们所说的“所有昨天”运动意味着现在艺术家说“我出于这个原因展示了带有巨大充气鼻子气球的三角龙”是非常合理的。你可以说，不，别这样做，那太推测性了，
that it would be equally justifiable to say, okay, for the time being, that's okay. That doesn't mean traceritops definitely had nose balloons. But by drawing it that way, it's like the artist is asking us to keep an open mind. Because even though we know a lot about the prehistoric world and more and more every day, the science is always changing. The past is always a moving target.
但同样可以说，好吧，目前为止，那没关系。这并不意味着三角龙肯定有鼻子气球。但通过那样画，就像艺术家在要求我们保持开放的心态。因为尽管我们对史前世界了解很多，而且每天都在了解更多，但科学总是在变化。过去总是一个移动的目标。
Piliwart is not just about drawing dinosaurs with stripes and nose balloons. Illustrators also depict dinosaur behavior, which may have even a greater impact on how we imagine extinct animals. More on that, after this. Hello, this is Emmett. I'm back with Roman in the studio to talk a little bit more about Paleoart. Hi, Roman. In this piece, we focused a lot on dinosaur appearance, like the look of their physical bodies, but there's like another pretty important issue with this, which is dinosaur behavior.
古生物艺术不仅仅是关于画带有条纹和鼻子气球的恐龙。插画家还描绘恐龙行为，这可能对我们如何想象灭绝动物有更大的影响。更多内容，稍后回来。你好，我是埃米特。我回到工作室和罗曼一起谈论更多关于古生物艺术的内容。你好，罗曼。在这篇文章中，我们重点关注了恐龙的外观，比如它们身体的样子，但还有一个关于这个的重要问题，那就是恐龙行为。
If you're going to draw a dinosaur, you're going to draw it. It's doing something. Doing something, right? And so when you think of dinosaur art, what are the dinosaurs usually doing? Usually the T-Rex is tearing something apart. Usually, at least when I was a kid, the Bronosaurus, as we mentioned, was staining us swamp with leaves sort of hanging out of its mouth. Right, like if it's like a meeting dinosaur,
如果你要画一只恐龙，你要画它。它在做某事。做某事，对吧？所以当你想到恐龙艺术时，恐龙通常在做什么？通常霸王龙在撕碎什么东西。通常，至少在我小时候，雷龙，正如我们提到的，在沼泽里站着，嘴里挂着叶子。没错，就像如果它是一只吃肉的恐龙，
it's probably eating another dinosaur, attacking another dinosaur. If it's a plant eating dinosaur, it's probably being attacked or like running away in some kind of way. Or eating a plant. I mean, it sort of seems to be like, whatever you ate as a dinosaur is what you should be depicted doing
它可能在吃另一只恐龙，攻击另一只恐龙。如果它是一只吃植物的恐龙，它可能正在被攻击或以某种方式逃跑。或者吃植物。我的意思是，它似乎是，无论你作为恐龙吃什么，就是你应该被描绘成正在做的事情
at any moment of its being depicted in form of art. Which like, you know, I mean, in some ways, it's not just the dinosaur thing. Like if you think about nature documentaries, we like to depict action. Totally. Like one was the last time you saw a cheetah doing anything other than running down a gazelle
在任何被描绘成艺术形式的时刻。这就像，你知道，我的意思是，在某些方面，这不仅仅是恐龙的事情。就像如果你想到自然纪录片，我们喜欢描绘动作。完全正确。就像你上次看到猎豹除了追逐瞪羚之外做任何事情是什么时候
and like biting its throat. But cheetahs do a lot of other things. They have a complex life. That's a real point, though, with art for people like Darren and John who are in our piece, is they think the lives of a lot of animals, including dinosaurs are a lot less action packed than it feels like when you are just looking at the art. They're not opening their mouths and roaring at the camera all the time, they're not just killing and fighting,
像咬它的喉咙。但猎豹还做很多其他事情。它们有复杂的生活。对于像达伦和约翰这样在我们的文章中的人来说，艺术的一个真正观点是，他们认为许多动物（包括恐龙）的生活远没有你在看艺术时感觉到的那么充满动作。它们不是一直张着嘴对着镜头咆哮，它们不仅仅是在杀戮和战斗，
they're doing things that living animals do, they're like, you know, moving around and sleeping and finding food and being boring a lot of the time. And you mentioned this earlier, but like I feel like of all the dinosaurs that we don't associate with that kind of like boring activity, like Tyrannosaurus Rex. Ranks like pretty high. Like of all the ones we associate with like action and violence. Yeah. It's T-Rex. Absolutely. It's always chomping at something. That's its role.
它们在做活着的动物做的事情，它们在移动、睡觉、寻找食物，而且大部分时间都很无聊。你之前提到了这一点，但我感觉在所有我们不与那种无聊活动联系在一起的恐龙中，比如霸王龙。排名相当高。在所有我们与动作和暴力联系在一起的恐龙中。是的。是霸王龙。绝对是。它总是咬着什么东西。这就是它的角色。
Even the end of Jurassic Park, its role is to end the movie by chomping a dinosaur in it. Right, right. And so when Darren and John were writing the book all yesterday, they obviously wanted to put a Tyrannosaurus in there. And John based his T-Rex painting on this one skeleton, this kind of famous skeleton that scientists
即使是《侏罗纪公园》的结尾，它的作用也只是通过咬死一只恐龙来结束电影。没错，没错。所以当达伦和约翰昨天写这本书时，他们显然想在里面放一只霸王龙。约翰根据这具骨架绘制了他的霸王龙，这具著名的骨架被科学家们
have nicknamed Stan. Stan is quite an aggressive looking tyrannosaurus in a way. It's got quite a large, long, scary looking head. And so Stan is traditionally depicted doing very nasty things to other animals. But John is also like pretty adamant, like that's not the whole truth of like who this creature was. They're probably going to kill something once every two weeks, you know. They spent the vast majority of their life asleep probably with a great big full belly just
昵称为“斯坦”。从某种程度上说，斯坦是一只看起来相当凶猛的霸王龙。它有一个相当大、长且看起来很吓人的头。因此，斯坦在传统上被描绘成对其他动物做非常残忍的事情。但约翰也非常坚持，那并不是这个生物真实面貌的全部。它们可能每两周才杀一次猎物，你知道的。它们绝大部分时间可能都是吃饱了肚子，
sleeping on the ground. And so that's how I painted it. So do you have that picture in the book? Yeah, yeah. So here's the book. Oh, you look so peaceful. Yeah, it's almost like a cute image. So here's the book. Oh, he looks so peaceful. Yeah, it's almost like a cute image. It's very cute. Yeah, just slightly curled up with its little tiny T-Rex arms
躺在地上睡觉。所以我就是这样画它的。书里有那张图吗？有，有。书就在这儿。哦，你看上去真安详。是的，这几乎是一个可爱的形象。书就在这儿。哦，他看起来真安详。是的，这几乎是一个可爱的形象。非常可爱。是的，只是稍微蜷缩着，它那小小的霸王龙手臂
up by its chin. This is one of John's favorite pieces from all yesterday's and he calls it a sleepy stan. Well, in fact, I mean, this picture, it doesn't even show his teeth when it's sleeping. Yeah. Which I don't think I've ever seen a T-rex picture without it burying its teeth, which is a stunning to think about that I've never, but I'm now, as I see it, I know it's true.
放在下巴旁边。这是约翰在《All Todays》中最喜欢的作品之一，他称之为“睡着的斯坦”。事实上，我的意思是，这张照片甚至没有露出它睡觉时的牙齿。是的。我想我从来没见过一张不露牙齿的霸王龙照片，这很令人震惊，因为我从来没见过，但现在我看到了，我知道这是真的。
I've never seen one without its teeth being shown in how long they are and probably ripping into flesh. But, yeah, we just, we don't show, to my honest, where I was just relaxing. And that's what they did most of the time. Right. It's probably pretty good life. Sleepy Stan.
我从来没见过不露牙齿的照片，它们看起来那么长，可能还在撕扯着血肉。但是，是的，我们只是，老实说，我们没有展示它，它只是在放松。这就是它们大部分时间在做的事情。没错。这可能是一种相当不错的生活。睡着的斯坦。
Sleepy Stan. Hold up. That's awesome. So if you flip Roman to like the back of the book, there's one more thing that I want to show you. So this back section of the book is actually called All Todays. And the idea behind this part of the book is it's sort of the actualization of that
睡着的斯坦。等等。太棒了。如果你把书翻到后面，还有一件事我想给你看。书的后半部分实际上叫《All Todays》。这本书这部分的理念是，它算是约翰·康威让我们做的那个思想实验的实现，
thought experiment that John Conway asked us to do, where you know you're imagining an alien paleontologist from the future who is trying to piece together what the contemporary world, the animals of the contemporary world look like based on fossil evidence. Right, so this picture I'm looking at now is a, is a manatee, but it's a land, a grazing land, herbivore. Right, can you read the description they have there?
你知道，你想象一位来自未来的外星古生物学家，他正试图根据化石证据拼凑出当代世界和当代世界的动物是什么样子的。没错，所以我现在看到的这张图是一只海牛，但它是一只陆地上的、吃草的食草动物。没错，你能读一下那里的描述吗？
It says, a solitary manatee is shown grazing in its mountain home. We only know the skull of this enigmatic herbivore. So basically, like in this case, they're saying, like, so with this animal, maybe we only, the only thing we ever got was the skull. And so, like, from that, you're trying to make you're like, oh, this looks a little bit like a cow skull. And it's totally common in dinosaurs, that they only find one little section. It's very rare that we find full skeletons to tell you everything about them. But anyway,
上面写着：一只孤独的海牛在它的山地家园中吃草。我们只知道这种神秘食草动物的头骨。所以基本上，就像这个例子一样，他们是说，对于这种动物，也许我们唯一得到的就是头骨。所以，从那一点出发，你试图推断，哦，这看起来有点像牛的头骨。这在恐龙中非常普遍，他们只发现了一小部分。我们很少能找到完整的骨架来告诉你关于它们的一切。但无论如何，
totally, you pick up a manatee skull and throw it off, you would think that's a cow. And even if you do find a full skeleton, there are other things that you could still miss. Totally. Oh, and this elephant, you wouldn't have a trunk to as evidence of this elephant, it's just this snub-nosed, weird-looking thing. Oh my God, oh, that's so true.
完全正确，如果你捡起一个海牛头骨扔掉，你会以为那是牛的头骨。即使你找到了完整的骨架，仍然有一些东西是你可能会错过的。完全正确。哦，还有这只大象，你不会有象鼻作为这只大象的证据，它只是一个塌鼻子、看起来很奇怪的东西。天哪，哦，那太真实了。
Right, so like a camel, the same way that we don't, and that's that we wouldn't necessarily know that a camel had humps, you wouldn't know that an elephant had trunk had a trunk, which is like such an iconic, weird piece of anatomy in the world. It's the thing that you define an elephant by, but it's not, it's not there and therefore,
没错，就像骆驼一样，同样地，我们不一定知道骆驼有驼峰，你也不会知道大象有象鼻，这可是世界上最具标志性、最奇怪的解剖结构。它是你定义大象的特征，但它不在那里，因此，
it doesn't look at all like an elephant, and it just looks absurd. I really like it. It really sells it, especially with these these speculative imaginings of modern animals. It really sells the idea of it a lot. Right. And they go, I like their text on some of these. So, like, if you read the swans, it like, yeah, say two swans are seen with their long, sith-like four limbs, which they must have used
它看起来一点也不像大象，看起来很荒谬。我真的很喜欢它。它真的很卖座，尤其是这些对现代动物的推测性想象。它确实很好地推销了这个想法。没错。而且他们做得很好，我喜欢他们对其中一些动物的文字描述。所以，如果你读到天鹅的部分，就像，是的，说两只天鹅长着长长的、像镰刀一样的前肢，它们一定是用这些前肢
to spear small prey items. One of them has just caught a tadpole, one of the mysterious fish of the past. Oh, it's so perfect. Right, so they really embody this, this futuristic scientist who's trying to piece together the world that we currently live in now and is making these kind of conceptual leaps from evidence to painting a real picture of what the world actually looked like. Yeah, but there's still everyone's doing their best. It's not like making fun of them.
来刺穿小猎物。其中一只刚刚抓到了一只蝌蚪，那是过去神秘的鱼类之一。哦，太完美了。没错，所以他们真的体现了这位试图拼凑我们现在所处世界的未来科学家，他正在从证据中进行这种概念上的飞跃，从而描绘出世界真实样子的真实图景。是的，但每个人都在尽力而为。这并不是在取笑他们。
No, it really is. It just has to, with the limited information we have, this is what we create. Right. And it really shows the limits of that information. Oh, it's so cool. It's such a good idea to think this way. It dislodges the iconography from your mind to be free. Exactly. You have to think about it in lots of ways. And that's really, and it really sells it when you see a modern animal depicted in the Swarche traditional dinosaur way. I kind of love that aspect of it. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Emmett Fitzgerald in 2018, mixed by Sirifusif, music by Sean Riel. Delaney Hall is the senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, throughout
不，确实不是。只是在信息有限的情况下，我们只能创造出这些。没错。它确实显示了这些信息的局限性。哦，太酷了。这样思考真是一个好主意。它将图标从你的脑海中剥离出来，让你获得自由。正是如此。你必须以多种方式思考它。当你看到一种现代动物以那种传统的恐龙方式被描绘出来时，它真的很有说服力。我有点喜欢它的那个方面。《99% Invisible》本周由 Emmett Fitzgerald 于 2018 年制作，由 Sirifusif 混音，Sean Riel 配乐。Delaney Hall 是高级制片人，Kurt Colstead 是数字总监，整个
the current team. It's Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemadon, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We were founded as a project of 91.7 K.A.L.W. in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the continent right now, but is centered, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX. Listen and support all the podcasts in our tribe at radiotopia.fm. You can Twitter me at Roman Mars in the show at 9-9-PI org,
当前的团队包括：Christopher Johnson、Vivian Le、Joe Rosenberg、Lashemadon、Katie Mingle、Sophia Klatsker 以及我 Roman Mars。我们最初是旧金山 91.7 K.A.L.W. 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作，现在分散在整个大陆，但中心位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的创始成员。请在 radiotopia.fm 收听并支持我们部落中的所有播客。你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars，或关注节目 @99PIorg，
or on Instagram and Reddit too. We have cool pictures of dinosaurs and really goofy pictures of dinosaurs at 99pi.org. of Donuts Wars at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From P-R-X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。我们在 99pi.org 上有很酷的恐龙图片和非常滑稽的恐龙图片。Radio Tapio。来自 P-R-X。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。